okay excellent there we go now
what's the big deal uh well not much at
the moment
this is just understanding what your two
unit and three volumes have already been
doing for quite some time
okay but just for the sake just to get
our heads into this space uh well let's
just work out this area right sorry
volume okay can we do it
how would it work out what would happen
i'm going to go straight back to the
formula right you get pi
from naught to four there's
y right so y squared would be x to the
four
two x squared one that's y squared isn't
it
or with respect to x cool no problems i
can do that
x to the 5 on 5 2 x cubed on 3
x from not to 4. is that ok
and at this point you can forget about
the fact that it's a volume
can't you right all you need to do is
just evaluate this guy
your lower bound is just going to be
zero so you're going to get all of this
stuff
four to the five on five um
four cubed on three four minus zero and
you'll get a number at the end
okay for the sake of um completeness why
don't you evaluate that number
but you get the point okay no big deal
but we've seen that this is um i mean
this is pretty pedestrian right this is
like
low level volumes right it starts to get
tricky
when your volumes have holes in them
okay so bear with me while i get some
more space
what happens when you get a hole in it
let's um let's take this same kind of
graph let's just move it up a little bit
x squared plus two just to give us a
little bit more room okay
now how would you introduce a hole into
a volume
okay well for instance you might say
introduce another line
let's put y equals one in there okay now
if i said
take an area between these two curves
okay
let's go from so i don't know
here maybe that's one
and that's three so now i have an area
and it's floating up off the axis
right so when i rotate it
what kind of shape are you going to get
can you see it
let's try it
there you go how is it how do you rate
it
is that okay it's reasonably accurate
right what i've got here
the same kind of volume that i had
before except
someone's chiseled a hole through it
okay no big deal now
how do we usually like how does three
unit u
how does three unit version of you
calculate this volume well you probably
work out this volume the way you worked
it out before
that's no problem okay and then because
you don't want this hole in there what
do you do
you have to do subtraction of volumes
don't you okay and that's not that big a
deal i mean it just so happens that
that's just a cylinder you could even
use pi r squared h on it
or alternatively if you think about what
this shape is going to be you just
integrate to get this volume and then
you subtract it no big deal
okay now that's what three unit you
would do
but we're in extension two today aren't
we so i'm going to give you a
very very subtle conceptual shift here
which when i show it to you with this
example you'll be like
what's the difference okay but it's
going to be sort of laying the
groundwork for where we're going to go
in the future
all right so here's what i want to do
remember we're talking about slices
right slices across this thing okay now
when you take slices of this they're not
going to be cylinders anymore
are they right the cylinder looks like
this
there you go there's my very very thin
cylinder
okay with a width of with a width of dx
or h or however you want to call it okay
i will not get such a
slice what am i going to get when i
slice across
perpendicular to the axis of rotation
yeah i'm going to kind of get a really
flattened doughnut aren't i okay
we have a name for this kind of shape
when i put my hole in it
okay the cross section of this
the cross section of this is called an
annulus
okay round thing with the hole in it um
it's an
annular slice right angular slice
so what i'm going to do is rather than
think about this as a subtraction of
volumes
okay subtraction volumes i want to come
back to your basic
first principle idea of how does this
how does this
how does this give you volume the answer
is it takes a whole bunch of slices and
adds them together
okay so i want to think about this and a
whole bunch of these
rather than this minus this does that
make sense
okay so how do i work out the volume of
this thing
how do you work out the volume of an
annular disc
hmm an angle slice well
you do have to do some subtraction don't
you can't avoid it right but i want to
do the subtraction here
rather than over here let's look at the
dimensions of this here okay
um you've got this round thing and it's
got two radii that you can talk about
okay so for instance you've got this
little
radius in here from the middle just to
the
inside of that ring i suppose okay and
then you've got a big
radius can you see that okay now people
call these
things different things some will call
it r1 r2 y1
y2 just my personal preferences i like
to call them little
r and big r because then you don't get
confused you're like which one's the big
one
it's the big r because it's bigger all
right so how do i work out the volume of
this thing
well you're gonna get pi outside of
right now you want the big one minus the
little one right like i said you can't
avoid any kind of subtraction
you do have a hole in there but i want
to take these shapes and add a whole
bunch of them together
big one minus the little one right and
if i want a volume then i have to
multiply by
whatever that width is right so you call
that
h or dx right
so now what i want to do is i want to
take not just one i want to take
all of them right between one and three
okay
so the way that i would do that is i
would say well we'll integrate from one
to three
and then i want a whole bunch of these
there you go and don't forget here
capital r and lowercase r right big r
and little r
they are actually not constant or they
don't have to be they're functions
they're functions of x okay which is why
i'm going to integrate with respect to x
okay so what's the what's capital r
what's it equal to how do i work that
out
now the thing is it's changing isn't it
depending on where i take the slice
okay but i know that wherever i am the
slice is going to be
that tall okay or the radius will be
that so that's my capital r
okay in the same way i read off this
function it's well it's just one
it is a constant so i'm getting uh
little r equals one
okay so now i do the integral one to
three
pi what am i going to get here x to the
four four x squared
plus four minus one
is that all right i mean that's actually
one squared but you get the picture okay
so now you've got this
and then away you go just like we did
before is that okay
that makes sense doesn't it now like i
said you're looking at this and thinking
what's the difference
what why not just um take one volume and
then subtract a little volume okay
what difference does it make to think of
it as an annulus first and then add up a
whole bunch
well watch i'll give you an example and
you'll see the power of this approach
which seems at the moment to be almost
identical okay